Donald Trump again in a courtroom but
for the first time on trial Trump his
adult sons and the Trump organization
are facing allegations of intentionally
inflating the value of Trump's real
estate holdings by nearly $3 billion in
order to gain more favorable loans that
is a crime one that could deal a major
blow to Trump's New York business Empire
it's a Witch Hunt Trump is not obliged
to attend the trial but on the first day
he did so voluntarily this trial was
railroaded and FasTrack this trial could
have been brought years ago but they
waited till I was right in the middle of
my campaign the investigation was years
in the making by New York's Attorney
General's office which brought the
charges last year Donald Trump and the
other defendants have con committed
persistent and repeated fraud last week
we proved that in our motion for summary
judgment today uh we will approve our
other claims the case is civil and not
criminal in nature there is no jury a
judge will rule if Trump is liable if
found liable Trump would have to pay
hundreds of millions of dollars in fines
the Attorney General is also asking for
a permanent ban on Trump and his adult
sons running businesses in New York and
a 5-year ban on Commercial Real Estate
activities Trump has said he's eager to
testify in the case even volunteering to
do so
Trump has already lost part of this case
when the judge last week ruled that he
was liable for fraudulently inflating
the value of his New York apartment the
trial now is dealing with six other
allegations this is the first of what
will likely be several trials involving
the former president over the next year
he's facing criminal indictments in
Florida Georgia Washington DC and
another one in New York it's a
disgraceful Tri trial but those trials
will come later next year right in the
middle of the Republican primary where
Trump is leading the polls as for this
trial there are more than a hundred
people on the potential witness list
meaning it could go on for weeks or
perhaps even months into December
Gabriel zando Al jazer New
York make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer